primo c'est le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur thierry mariani
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur le décret tant attendue
concernant les permis de conduire des
français établis à l'étranger vient
d'être enfin publié et j'ai envie de
lire hélas tant d'attentes pour si peu
un décret qui ne touche en fin de compte
qu'une toute petite partie des français
de l'étranger et donc fortement décevant
mais ce décret laisse malheureusement de
nombreux problème de résolu non résolus
pardon à l'heure où nombre de nos
compatriotes s'expatrient résoudre leurs
contraintes administratives var est
aujourd'hui indispensable d'autant plus
monsieur le premier ministre que cela ne
coûte rien et nous avions commencé à
alerter l'attention de votre
gouvernement sur ce sujet quand vous
même étiez d'ailleurs à l'époque
ministre de l'intérieur ce qui est ce
qui n'est pas très compliqué à mettre en
place peut pourtant changé beaucoup de
choses
actuellement par exemple s'il ans
résidant thaïlande ou en australie
c'est la croix et la bannière pour
obtenir un duplicata de son permis de
conduire
quand allons nous donc autorisé les
postes consulaires à délivrer des
duplicatas de permis de conduire en cas
de perte ou de vol
et en cas de perte de permis
internationaux
quand allons nous permettre aux
personnes qui passent leur permis dans
un pays où il n'ya pas d'accords de
réciprocité de revenir en france et de
ne pas repasser ce permis
quand allez vous permettre le
rétablissement des droits à conduire
auprès de la préfecture pour l'ensemble
des non résidents lors de leur retour en
france je le disais en incluant les pays
sans accord de réciprocité
enfin quand allez-vous étudier avec les
assureurs la possibilité de prendre en
compte les années de conduite des
expatriés pour fixer leurs tarifs et
pour les permis de conduire à validité
limitée
quand allez vous enfin donner la
possibilité d'effectuer une visite
auprès d'un médecin agréé par le
consulat ça fait trois ans et demi que
l'ensemble des parlementaires on sait on
fait en ces demandes
ça fait trois ans et demi qu'on
attendait ce décret ce décret décevant
est ce qu'on aura enfin une réponse pour
tous ces français merci monsieur mariani
la parole et à monsieur harlem d
dire secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry mariani je veux d'abord excusé
bernard cazeneuve qui comme vous le
savez est retenu mais je veux répondre à
votre question très importante sur la
situation des français établis hors de
france au regard de la réglementation
sur les permis de conduire
la directive de 2008 et la convention de
vienne prévoit que les permis de
conduire ne puisse être délivré par un
état qu aux usagers qui résident dans
cet état juridiquement il n'est donc pas
possible qu'un dispositif réglementaire
sa franchise de ce cadre cependant tout
en étant conforme à ce cadre juridique
le décret du 22 mars 2016 relatif au
permis de conduire apporte des
aménagements il vise ainsi à apporter
des solutions pratiques à nos
concitoyens expatriés qui sans être
résident permanent l'étranger souhaité
renouveler leur permis de conduire
notamment au moment de l'installation et
avant un échange contre le permis locale
ce décret s'appliquerait plus
particulièrement à deux situations
premièrement aux usagers en cours
d'installation dans un pays hors de
l'union européenne et qui viendraient à
perdre ou à se faire voler leurs titres
avant d'avoir pu échanger contre le
permis local deuxièmement aux usagers
qui par leur statut particulier
c'est le cas des étudiants sont établis
à l'étranger mais ne sont pas considérés
comme résidant et peuvent donc conduire
avec le permis français plutôt qu'avec
un permis locales les français résidant
à l'étranger depuis plusieurs années et
conduisant par conséquent avec un permis
locales sont pour ce qui les concerne
non concernées par cette réglementation
enfin pour mémoire ce décret entrera en
vigueur au début de l'été prochain à
compter du 1er juillet 2016 mais le
gouvernement est évidemment à votre
disposition pour tenter de régler les
cas qui ne le serait pas à l'issue de
cette réglementation jour merci merci la
parole d'atr